شابه سعوديه استطاعت رغم قصر قامتها
وتحديات نظره المجتمع لها ان تبتكر سياره
كهربائيه للحرم المكي بعد ان حصلت على
درجه البكالوريوس مع مرتبه الشرف الاولى
في تخصص تصميم منتجات تنافسيه تساهم في
الاقتصاد المعرفي وخدمه المجتمع من خلال
الابتكار ومواكبه التطورات التقنيه
الحديثه في التصميم اختلافه دان الهاجري
هو ما يميزها ويشعرها باهميه الدخول الى
مضمار التحديات والمنافسات لتثبت نفسها في
كل مرحله حتى تصل الى ما تريد وتنجح في
مشروعها الاخير وهو سياره كهربائيه تخدم
ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه في الحج
[موسيقى]
ايش هو مشروعك اليوم اللي انت افتكرتيه
للحج والعمره
ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه
في حاله الى
اقرباء
وتحديت الاعاقه وحققت هذا النجاح الكبير
حصلتي على براءه اختراع وهذا بالتاكيد
انجاز كبير يعني كيف تولد الشرف عندك
بعيدا عن هذا تخصص الجامعه يعني من طفولتك
انت احب اني
افتكر حلول بسيطه
من البيت يعني
كنت انا والدتي
بس بابسط الامور مثلا ابي افتح الباب
وادخل واطلع
معتمد على نفسي فابسط شيء كنا نفكر
بالحبال نربطها على كل عراوي الباب
من عشر سنين يعني يمكن 10 سنين الى امك
هذا عمر 22 سنه من الحبال هذه ما نفكر
استخدمها وافتح فيها يعني
كان عندي هذا الشهر اني اطلع من اشياء
بسيطه
لهم يعني ايش حابه توصل الرساله هذول
الشباب
كل منه فيه قوه داخليه لكن يحتاج انه يثق
فيها يستغلها ما تاثر في الظروف ولا ولا
احيانا ممكن المجتمع فا تجارب حياتك بناء
على الشيء داخل فيه اذا كنت مهزوز اذا كنت
ضعيف او اذا كنت ثابت فكل ما تحصل عليه
تجارب بالحياه بناء على الشيء اللي داخل
لك
تستغل هذه الطاقه بدل ما تكون يعني مستنفه
الى طاقه مغذيه لك
[موسيقى]